foreign
to Los Angeles California and talk to
Shelly what's up Shelly
hi hi can you hear me yeah I can how are
you
I am good how are you good good good
good good what's up
um sorry I'm a little nervous I'm
nervous too I'm nervous too so we can
just be nervous together
yes um so my question is how can I move
past
the history that I had with my husband
while he was drinking now that he is
sober and is it even possible
uh I don't know what is
um what there's a lot there um why do
you want to move past it
because I feel like I
I can't be connected with him anymore
um
I guess I'll just explain I
she was we've been married for uh four
years and he was drinking for I guess
three and a half of those
um but it just progressively got worse
and I did threaten many times to leave
of course but eventually I uh I did
and I went to go stay with my aunt and
uncle and I kind of was just trying to
figure out my life because I was just
done and um only after I left did he
finally go to AAA and decide to change
so I came back and
the last few months have just been I I
can't get intimate with him I I can
barely hug him honestly I feel like
when he is even like touching me like I
just get like almost the defense
mechanism you know why how come
like what is your body trying to protect
you from
often often when we say I had to step
away from a relationship whether it was
romantic or a friendship or something
like a marriage we step away from
somebody who's struggling with addiction
it's often the behaviors that surround
the addiction so did he hit you did he
cheat on you was he with other people
like what were the things that were
happening while he was not sober
um so he did not hit me or anything like
that
um I mean he got aggressive
with me but like mostly verbally that he
would
pretty much like uh drink excessively
and then if we would go out there were a
lot of times where he would act out and
I mean I lost a lot of friends
um you know because he kind of just
turned into a crazy person
um and you know then sometimes like if I
would go out he would
get drunk and then freak out that I was
out like just and then why do you want
to go back you left
yeah you played a game of chicken with
him for a while which is I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna you never did and then
finally you did
and it sounds like
um we forget this
alcoholism all addictions but alcoholism
um
can often be highly environmental in
nature
and most people when they enter into
sobriety and they go to AAA they don't
realize you got to change friends you
got to change coping strategies you got
to change places to go hang out you got
to change everything
and
um
you left the environment
and you found peace
you left the environment and he was able
to Exhale and go get help
so what is it about you wanting to re
like engage in this thing I don't see
anywhere where you love him where you
want to go be with him you want to
rekindle with him
in fact your body's telling you the
exact opposite so why why are you going
to go back
oh I mean
I guess
because I I married him and and I I did
go into this with love and I
I wanted I wanted to be that way I guess
and I I want to heal and I guess I
always wanted him to be a certain way
and he wasn't and then
when I left suddenly he's like oh wait
actually I will change and um now that
he is
I guess I just wish that I that I could
feel that way and I wish that we could
just heal can I can I give you an
alternate explanation
yeah
you you had a picture of what marriage
was going to look like you had a picture
of what he was going to look like but
over time you didn't like who you became
yeah and you lost trust in you
and now you're back
and when the sobriety when people get
sober they have to deal with this
ugly reality which is real life
on both sides of the equation that's why
people who struggle with certain
addictions
um their Partners often can't survive
the transition to sobriety because
that's not the person I married or
that's not what I signed up for this
sober person I like the fun person the
silly person the spontaneous person The
Moody dark person I like that I didn't
like the excesses but I liked that part
and I don't know what to do with this
cheerful guy or this thoughtful guy or
this guy that picks up after himself and
goes to work every day
what about you do you not like in this
new
ly sober husband of yours
I
um it's hard to explain but I think the
main thing is that
I
I
really
um degraded Myself by putting myself
through what I went through
and when I finally went to my aunt and
uncle and my aunt is like
basically my mom
um she really kind of explained to me
that I can't keep doing that and I think
I got that in my head and now
anything that he tries to do just
doesn't help because I'm now like no I
respect myself and I'm not gonna let you
take any advantage ever again like I
don't know is he continuing to try to
take advantage of you while you're sober
no no he's actually trying to be better
and I can see that and I guess that
makes me feel guilty okay so he's not on
the phone so the only person I can talk
to is you and I'm gonna give you
probably some wisdom that nobody's given
you okay
okay
um
you chose to go back
yeah and if you choose to go back and
now you discover that you have power
because a a is about taking a knee it's
about saying I submit I tapped out
what the way I was trying to do life was
not working and it was burning me and
everybody else to the ground
so you've come back and now the tide has
turned and you've got power
and you are killing this guy
you're starving him to death
your dangling love over a great uh
Cavern
and then you're pulling it back every
time he tries
and in a weird way that's that's cruel
do you get what I'm saying
I do and so either here's here's what
most people who re-enter relationships
like this here's the mistake
we just wanted to get back to the way
things used to be
yeah we want it to be I want to be like
remember when we dated and remember when
we laughed all the time and we made out
wherever and remember our wedding and
remember all we wanted to get back to
the way things were
hear me say directly there is no going
back there is only creating something
entirely new
entirely new
and you'll still have the memories
you'll still have to hurt you'll have
new boundaries you'll have some
protective measures
but you have to go all in
not in being who you used to be and him
being who he used to be but in being
completely new people for one another so
that you can re-engage this marriage and
if you're not willing to do that don't
torture him
he's got enough on his plate
yeah is that fair
that is that makes a lot of sense are
you willing to
like um am I willing to let go no no no
no no are you willing to
say okay this is what was and it all
fell down
if you've listened to the show for any
length of time you've heard me use the
analogy about 9 11.
we could never go sweep up all the steel
and glass and wood and all the papers
that were scattered for Miles we could
never sweep all that stuff back up and
use those materials to rebuild the Twin
Towers in Manhattan you have to excavate
the whole thing it all has to be moved
out thrown into the dump or recycled and
you got to clear the whole deck out and
you got to design and build something
new
see what I'm saying and what you're
trying to do is to sweep up all that
stuff and halfway through sweeping up
the stuff you say I don't want to do
this anymore
yeah
yeah and I'm not debate I I bet man you
could probably make my skin crawl with
some of the things you've experienced
yeah definitely he's screaming in public
the embarrassment the the sexual
advances you didn't want even though you
were married like all the stuff man not
to mention the stuff that you probably
don't know about or you've chosen to not
know about I'm not saying it's easy I'm
just saying you chose to come back
and if you chose to choose to come back
halfway
to a guy who's trying to re-commit his
life to himself and to you that's cruel
yeah
if I'm wrong tell me
it doesn't feel like it's
I almost feel like I'm not choosing like
I'm like am I I want to I want to get
better but I can't help it's like
flashbacks like I see see what he's
capable of and it's hard for me to move
on from that that's exactly right and so
I'd recommend a couple of things here
um number one you have to develop
your own voice you've got to develop
your strength from the inside out what
does that mean that means you need to
sit with a counselor and
be open and honest about what you
experienced
get those things out of your heads those
flashbacks you say those haunting
memories get them out of your head onto
paper into conversation with somebody
else usually in your situation that's
best had with a therapist you're gonna
have to learn how to create boundaries
very very firm boundaries boundaries
like you cannot swear in this home at me
period if you swear in this home you are
choosing to leave or I am choosing to
leave
you cannot hide money in our home we
will have one single joint checking
account because we're married and we're
going to put like see what I'm saying
like you'll have to have really strong
boundaries and then you're gonna have to
practice that when those lightning bolt
thoughts pop in your head the thoughts
of remember that time he started
screaming in a in a restaurant and
caused a scene because he was drunk like
an idiot again
you stop and you exhale not doing that
today
he's sober now
he's sober now and I'm gonna practice
going back into restaurants with him
I'm gonna feel the discomfort in my body
I'm gonna lean into that discomfort I'm
not going to run away from it because
otherwise if I keep running that
discomfort becomes reinforced in my own
physiology my body reinforces so next
time it'll send more thoughts and
they'll be louder and more more obtuse
and more graphic I'm going to remember
remember and I'm not saying you forget
you'll always know what he's capable of
the new building you build will have new
reinforcements in it
and you can't base your health or
Wellness on trying to fix him that's his
work he's got to do with himself and his
sponsor and his community
but if you're gonna go back
you've got to do the work to be all in
and be well and honestly I think you
should
I don't know what you've been through so
maybe if we sat down I'd be like honey
run run but just from this limited
conversation I think you're worth that I
think he's worth that
I think this marriage that y'all put put
forth is worth that
but if you come back you got to go all
then
All In